I love it 80 Canada love yes Canada yeah
well we're loving you guys how many how
many films would you say you're done
together at this point it's actually
like number 10 I don't remember Nick
being in a movie with me in the back I
think it's probably good that many yeah
it probably is Grandma's Boy
Benchwarmers chuck and Larry do over
ridiculous six fit all this many clearly
there's one friend that cares more than
the other in this way I talk to all the
extras of the movie everyone's important
to me why are you asking Nick about his
haircut this is the big story is this
your um is your your quarantine cut did
you do that on your own yeah I'm from
Minnesota which is just south of Canada
and so this is not uncommon an uncommon
hair cutter oh yes
Minnesota we caught hockey here it's
basically spring training haircut goes
all the games hey if you guys had to UM
let down somebody easy like someone
you're gonna do with your life this is
gonna wear yeah how do you let them down
easily without causing a scene or really
earned their clothes I do it through
zoom no Nick doesn't do text he just
doesn't answer anymore like we always
have planned things like oh dude is that
tonight I'm like yeah this is super old
oh yeah oh yeah I can't cuz I was gonna
go to Mike my other friend's house and
watch it Oh David will text me hey you
want to see a movie yeah sure when five
minutes I'm like alright I'll just skip
my dad's funeral just come just okay I'm
not gonna say anything one of the big
stories that everyone's been talking
about from Netflix is Tiger King and
like
across the board when we were no talking
about oh if they become a miniseries or
a movie about this David Spade has got
to play the lead like David Spade has
got a play an entire King and they're
doing one with Nicolas Cage David did
you ever hear about people saying you
got to do this or did you ever have your
eye on that everyone tells me that Nick
Swardson should play one of the tiger
poops but I don't know that's gonna go
to but Nicolas Cage I think he's great I
listen that thing start I was like a fun
Internet thing just people to vote
there's nothing to do so like he's not
your king and then yesterday I saw some
people on Twitter revolting that I
wasn't in it but I would do something
like that I just I it's so funny already
I don't know what Nick's opinion is but
when they're so funny like that I don't
know what the angle is to make it to do
just do exactly what they already did
because it was so surprisingly funny
every episode like Carole Baskins funny
this again the boyfriend comes and he's
crazy everyone's crazy and different so
to make that hilarious is already sort
of funny I don't know what they're gonna
make me dramatic I don't know yeah it's
already absurd so how do you out absurd
reality you can't you know I heard I
heard that they were like no it's not
gonna be what you saw it'll be like a
continuation or something I like I don't
know what but they said it's not like
what you've already seen so I don't know
I guess they can just embellish anything
and just pretend like no that's actually
no he's now married to a zebra or I mean
I just feel like maybe I if I had a
great angle I would have probably tried
to do so I did have any angles alright
so how many angles
do you have angles on your head right
now like this guy's can you talk a bit
about what makes Lauren so great in this
film like she really goes for it
physical comedy she's hilarious
well for me I had kind of known her
peripherally just through friends and
knew her name and stuff like that and
then when I went when I got on set and
saw her you can always tell when
somebody
is great right away it's pretty clear
and uh for her the first thing I saw her
do um I was like oh this she's great
like she just you can tell by someone's
commitment and you can just you can it's
hard to explain you can just town I knew
right away I was like oh because she she
is the movie you know what I mean if you
don't have somebody who's not game for
anything and all those stunts and all
that absurdity then the movie just
doesn't work you know so when I write
when I saw her I was like oh this
movie's gonna be yeah okay cool we're
good I agree when you watch it's like
singers watching singers you can tell
right away like if you're a comedian or
in the comedy rodeo she's got some game
and I saw her audition and then when she
came on you know it's a little stressful
because she's coming in at mad as a
movie we I know Nick we all know each
other and then she might be intimidated
but it's also a female-driven happy
Madison where we haven't really done
that and she has to be funny and every
take and I'm sort of the straight guy so
Nick's really funny
Sneijder fun they're they're funny the
way they are which is great and they get
to make up and be crazy but that was
sort of shoveled on Lauren everything
played this way players are making up
different lines stick him in the script
don't stick with and every every take
I'm like she's really coming through it
we have we had so much to pick from
you'd even know what's gonna wind up in
the movie that's awesome guys thanks so
much for your time Nick your haircut
looks amazing it's fantastic like Dave
thanks for those duper long answer so I
didn't get to anything else to ask you
but great now it's great guys thanks a
lot yeah man good to meet you cross you
say bye guys
you